[Music]
he was really interested in people he
didn't ever told you what to do he sort
of said just do it well and he knew all
a machinist and he coined the term
instrumentation the room was just packed
you know you were dealing with a power
he was really excited by space he said I
guarantee if you stay away that you'll
have a lot of fun
he had his degree from Stanford I think
in psychology and he came here almost as
a tourist and was intrigued by it and
I've heard I can't prove this that he
took more courses for credit at MIT than
anybody has ever taken he was the man
responsible for the beginnings of the of
the supersonic era in the department
Draper's excitement although he was a
pilot liked to fly and he was really
excited by space and so under Draper's
tutelage the department moved in that
direction a lot further than it had ever
been I am a fellow who was a teacher at
MIT and probably always sort of a
low-ranking teacher I was there and six
was called 1641 basic instrumentation
the room was just packed you could just
sort of feel the tempo of it right off
the start and he said I would give you a
little philosophy first he said if you
guys are really interested and a lot of
nightlife and so on you're in the wrong
place he said you're never going to make
over $10,000 a year in this field but
you said I'll guarantee if you stay away
that you'll have a lot of fun and I went
down with dr. aper to the Sperry
gyroscope company and he stood up in
front of a whole bunch of engineers at a
little auditorium there and sketched out
how you could put in that so-called
target acquisition system and after that
I said that was a pretty complicated
chart and doc said look when you're
giving a talk he said you always want to
make most the chart simple so people
think they understand it but I always
throw in one they're so complicated they
think this guy must be really smart and
you don't understand if we know he knows
what he's talking
and then he became interested in
airplane instruments he was a pilot I
used to fly it he used to fly out at
Logan field before I was called Logan I
think hunters know about trying to try
to lead the target the right amount and
dark felt that the way to go about it
was to make use the fact that in
tracking a target you had to obviously
follow it and and that very motion of
following should help you predict what
the lead angle is so that when the
bullet got out to the vicinity of the
target it would actually be be a hit and
you'd actually knocked the target down
dark sight was being used at just about
the time that the camicazi were really
raising the devil with with our Navy out
in the Pacific the kamikazes were
getting smart enough they were always
coming in with a Sun behind them doc had
put in a system for tracking that the
raid I was just becoming available well
you put the antenna on the gun mount so
if all of a sudden the the kamikaze has
a Sun behind you can close off the the
optics and you could still track with a
radar signal that was with a mirror and
so on put right in the line of sight of
the of the tracker when I was an
undergraduate here in the electrical
engineering department this is now in
the sort of early 50s 49 50 51 kind of
they used to talk about this crazy guy
in the Aero Department who was going to
make a measurement of acceleration with
an accelerometer or mechanical
instrument that had a little spring and
a mass in it and he was going to
integrate that to get velocity and then
integrate that again and find out where
you were and everybody went ha ha ha
everybody knows that if you make a
little error in that measurement you're
going to integrate it twice and have a
huge error of course Draper knew that
and particular you have to make
extremely precise instruments we still
have to make this equipment cheaper than
it is now but I am sure that as time
goes along you will find inertia
guidance equipment not in the advanced
military weapons but you will find it in
commercial vehicles on the land in the
sea in the air and in space
and I'm also I believe on farm grounds
if I say that 10 years from today
inertial guidance will be such an
ordinary thing that it will not be even
remarked by the people who are using it
every time I would mention a ring laser
gyroscope or laser gyroscope what have
you he he always said that you're
wasting your time was a Draper's power
so strong that he could just say ok
we're not going to investigate yeah he
had a lot of power because all of Jarrah
work most of Jarrah work going on at MIT
we're not in the instrumentation 11 he
was the director of it yeah so he was
not a person to take lightly I mean even
if phasing in gone in there but with
other funding when you sit there with
Doc on his desk and explain what you're
doing and see him explode and so on you
know you were dealing with a power my
facilities consisted of a broom closet
somewhere in which I could keep my
little pieces of paper and the
second-hand equipment I had usually the
first thing he did when he came in in
the morning was to go down the machine
shop he loved to go down and see what
was going on and and he knew all of
Machinists and maybe was a test going on
of a gyro and he'd go in and see how the
test had gone all night
he was really interested in people even
though he was working a lot of
mathematical areas and a lot of fussy
mechanical electromechanical areas and
then you take people out to dinner and
then very often he come back in the lab
and though his serious thinking his
serious mathematical work the writing he
was doing on umpteen books that were
written he would purposely start a rumor
in his lab when he had to eat a pretty
good-sized lab and then he'd go down and
prowl around and he would measure the
time it took for one of his rumors to
spread to some of the part of the lab
and he did this knowingly what did he
have a purpose sure he wanna know who
was talking to whom in the lab but there
was always this undercurrent of should
it be
as an airplane or should it be should it
be space and this kind of went on and on
and I can't remember the year but
Doolittle was on the visiting committee
and he was famous and he was starting to
you know age a little to where he was
certainly a senior person with a great
deal of respect and he had listened all
day through this talk on the state of
the department the directions it was
going to move in and so forth
and in front of the podium where doc had
been most of the day he had some of the
others talking but he was doing most of
it and most of it was about the
activities that were going to happen in
space there was a sign that said
Department of aeronautics and
astronautics and it just sort of fit in
the scene almost the whole day towards
the end of the day Doolittle stands up
and he says you know you've gone so hard
over for space you've completely
forgotten about an Aeronautics and to
the extent that it's misspelled on that
side and it was the first thing the rest
of the group had even seen its
misspelling it just broke the whole
place up Draper coins the term
instrumentation history seems to say to
us maybe that wasn't the right word
because it always got confused was the
medical instrumentation but it was a
good word because it was new and as
excited and people associated with
Draper doc himself realized that
instrumentation the word need to be sort
of expanded and he came up with a word
what infra medics I think was it yeah
that's very interesting because he
coined the word informatics and now
we're saying that there are these new
thrusts and information and in humans of
automation yeah and he already had them
together yeah and they're they're
certainly in our department will be
strong links between those two you know
so they asked me if I could make the
equipment that would
to the moon and back and I think yes I
could who I said how would I guarantee
this and I said I would go wrong and run
it myself
what's the count now of astronauts that
have passed through the Aero Department
I don't know the total count from MIT is
equals any other institution except the
Naval Academy well I would say a
milestone was when the Institute
divested the Draper lab I think there
was a major shock to the department the
divestment of the divestment of the
Dre's are riding away from that part
that's right the laboratory has followed
a trail that I suppose I started
probably by accident I don't know if
that had as its primary idea that human
beings should be allowed to work on
anything and that seemed to be
worthwhile and they had enough steam to
want to do by themselves and their
success or failure was always judged on
one thing and only one thing and is
whether they made something that was of
enough used to somebody on the outside
so we could get some money paid in to
our resources to keep us going
people asked me what do you like about
the aero department why have you been
here all your life and I think it was
the standard that he set for camaraderie
he didn't ever told you what to do he
sort of said you know you just do it
well and he gave you a very free rein
what what did you do differently from
what other people were doing at that
time I simply made things that worked